[Musique]
en 1986 les téléspectateurs français
découvrent une nouvelle série animée
dont ils n'imaginent
devenir en quelques années un véritable
phénomène générationnel dragon ball
dragon ball c'est l'histoire de sangoku
un enfant avec une queue de singe qui se
retrouve embarqué malgré lui dans une
histoire de boule de cristal de dragon
qui apparaît et de souhaits exaucés
l'une des particularités de sangoku
c'est sa maîtrise des arts martiaux
accompagné d'une force physique
phénoménale
un atout qui lui permettra de venir à
bout de ses adversaires les plus
redoutables eux aussi engagés dans la
quête des boules de cristal les
événements conduiront sangoku à devenir
le protecteur de la planète terre ne
reculant devant aucun ennemi et faisant
preuve d'un courage à toute épreuve
lorsque son frère lui révélera la vérité
sur ses origines le fait qu'il
appartient à la race des saïan un peuple
de guerriers sens et conquérir la
galaxie
sangoku comprend qu'il est réellement il
comprend d'où lui vient cette
combativité hors pair et ce talent inné
pour les arts martiaux mais il comprend
aussi que vivre parmi les terriens a
fait de lui un terrien et qui luttera
désormais pour sa planète d'adoption et
non pour celle qui l'a vu naître
sangoku tue son frère en l'apprenant le
prince des saïan décide de se rendre sur
terre pour retrouver l'assassin de son
congénère san goku est sur le point de
rencontrer son plus grand rival
son frère ennemi l'un des personnages
les plus marquants de l'univers dragon
ball végéta végéta fait partie des rares
personnages d'une oeuvre narrative à
avoir acquis une popularité quasiment
supérieure à celle du personnage
principal
impitoyable orgueilleux mais prison
végéta et le double obscur de sangoku il
avait prévu de conquérir la terre et
leur massacrer les habitants
mais à force de côtoyer les terriens il
a fini par coexister avec eux mêmes
parents de venir un sous de nombreux
aspects et gta est un personnage à la
psychologie complexe travaillé par des
conflits intérieurs et un besoin
permanent de prouver sa valeur mais si
on devait dresser le portrait
philosophique de végéta qu'est ce que ça
donnerait quels sont les philosophies
qui influence sans qu'ils le sachent
la vision du monde de végéta
c'est ce que je vous propose de
découvrir dans cet épisode
[Musique]
s'il ya un mot qui caractérise le
personnage de végéta c'est la puissance
non pas au sens où il serait le
personnage le plus puissant de la série
mais au sens où devenir le plus puissant
et son unique obsession
dès qu'il rencontre un adversaire plus
puissant que lui cette idée
l'insupportent au point de se sentir
obligé de l'affronter quand bien même
ils auraient conscience de n'avoir
aucune chance
préférant être tué par un ennemi que
sauvé par un ami végétal est
l'incarnation de ce que nietzsche
appelait la volonté de puissance la
volonté de puissance
c'est un concept qui désigne la force
qui anime toute chose qui vit et qui
d'après nietzsche permettrait aux êtres
humains de dépasser leur humanité pour
accéder au statut de surhumain la
volonté de puissance est à l'oeuvre
aussi bien dans les phénomènes naturels
que dans les comportements humains
l'expriment m c'est célébrer cette force
vitale qui anime le monde et sans
laquelle nous n'existerions pas végéta
incarne la volonté de puissance car
végéta ne respecte que la puissance les
seuls personnages pour lesquels végéta
éprouve un semblant de respect sont
toujours des personnages qu'il sait être
plus fort que lui
ils méprisent la gentillesse et la
dévotion qui ne sont pour lui que des
masques de la faiblesse à l'image de
nietzsche qui voyait dans la morale une
création des faibles pour se protéger
des forts la seule morale qui est une
valeur selon nietzsche
c'est la morale de la puissance
précision très importante la volonté de
puissance n'implique pas forcément un
désir de détruire ou de faire du mal
contrairement aux jeunes végéta qui ne
cache pas son plaisir à faire souffrir
des innocents de ce point de vue là il
serait davantage à rapprocher du marquis
de sade que de nietzsche mais la pulsion
sadique de végéta ne dure qu'un temps et
au fur et à mesure du récit sa quête de
puissance se canalise var un objectif
unique battre san goku sangoku avec et
végéta partagent une caractéristique
commune et que nietzsche a résumé dans
une formule célèbre ce qui ne nous tue
pas nous rend plus fort cette phrase
résonne évidemment d'une manière
spéciale pour les fans de dragon ball
qui savent que la particularité des
saïan c'est qu'ils deviennent beaucoup
plus fort à chaque fois qu'il frôle la
mort il est certain qu'un pirate riam à
l'auteur de dragon ball avait cette idée
en tête lorsqu'il a imaginé cette
particularité
ce que confirme une analyse globale de
l'oeuvre laquelle met continuellement
l'accent sur la nécessité de dépasser
ses limites pour devenir meilleur pour
devenir un surhumain déjà incarne la
volonté de puissance car végéta qu'on
soit l'existence comme un affrontement
de force dont il doit sortir vainqueurs
mais il serait un peu réducteur de
résumer la personnalité de végéta à sa
quête de puissance car ce serait omettre
un élément majeur de sa conception du
monde
le sens du devoir végéta est le fils du
roi végéta qui a donné son nom à la
planète dont proviennent les sayan en
qualité de prince des saïan végéta ce
fait une obligation morale de
représenter dignement ce statut les
valeurs morales de végéta sont en
correspondance avec sa vision
aristocratique du monde
il est l'héritier d'une lignée de
combattants prestigieux et il entend
bien le faire savoir
c'est ce qui le conduira lorsqu'il sera
dominée dans un combat à hurler de
colère qu'il est le prince des saïan
comme pour s'obliger à être à la hauteur
de ce titre les jettent à est loin
d'être l'incarnation de la morale ces
crimes sont nombreux et ils assument ne
pas être un homme bon
mais lorsqu'il s'agit de son honneur les
mots de la morale de kant semblent
ressentir dans son cerveau
tu toi quand tu es connu pour sa
philosophie morale très stricte dans
laquelle il attribue une place
prépondérante à la notion de devoir le
devoir nous dit quand est ce qui doit
guider chacun de nos actes
il n'existe aucun passe-droit à la
morale autrement dit le devoir est
quelque chose qui doit s'imposer à nous
de manière absolue
s'il ya un domaine dans lequel végéta
incarne la morale de quand c'est bien le
domaine du combat
même en proie à la peur au désespoir ou
à l'épuisement le devoir de se battre et
la seule chose qui compte pour lui au
point de prendre la forme de ce que
quand tu as plein un impératif
catégorique
un siècle après quand sigmund freud
approfondira la question du devoir
en forgeant une notion qui s'applique
particulièrement bien à la personnalité
de végéta le surmoi le surmoi c'est
l'instance morale de notre psychisme
c'est ce qui nous commandent d'agir
selon certains principes principe qui ne
sont essentiellement transmis par
l'éducation végétal est le fils d'un roi
il a grandi avec l'idée qu'il devait
être le meilleur et qui lui était
interdit d'être faibles sont sur moi et
structurée par le sens de l'honneur
la volonté de puissance de végéta n'est
non pas une volonté chaotique et
désordonnée
c'est une volonté encadré par un idéal
moral qu'il se fait un devoir de
respecter
si le personnage de végétal est autant
apprécié par les fans de dragon ball
ce n'est pas seulement en raison de sa
quête de puissance ou de son sens de
l'honneur
c'est aussi et surtout parce que c'est
un personnage qui évolue la première
fois qu'il apparaît dans la série
végéta koch toutes les cases de
l'antagoniste parfait il est cruel
incroyablement fort dévoré par le désir
de renier et dénuée du moindre scrupule
alors jusqu'à tuer ses propres alliés
pour bien faire comprendre à ses
adversaires
à quel genre d'homme ils ont à faire les
choses basculent après son premier
combat contre san goku à l'issue duquel
sangoku vainqueur laisse végète à partir
au lieu de lui donner le coup de grâce
ce geste de clémence sera 100 végétal
sache l'acte qui initiera son évolution
et son intégration progressive
parmi les terriens car lorsqu'il
recroisera les amis de sangoku peu de
temps après il épargnera celui qui lui
avait laissé la vie sauve
contraint de s'allier avec son goku et
sa bande végétale finira par devenir
titulaire du groupe des guerriers
terriens il épousera même l'une d'entre
elles celle sur qui reposent l'entièreté
du récit avec qui il aura un fils qui
aura plusieurs fois l'occasion de sauver
la terre et ses habitants
végéta est conscient de son évolution
tout au long du récit et parfois même il
cela reprochent ils se reprochent son
adoucissement sa domestication qui l'a
fait passer de prince des saïan à bon
père de famille il se reproche de s'être
lui-même condamné à rester le numéro 2
l'ombre de sangoku planant sur lui même
depuis le royaume des morts dans le
dernier chapitre de la série
végéta ira jusqu'à se laisser envoûter
par un sorcier maléfique pour retrouver
sa cruauté d'antan et renouer avec son
destin originel être le plus fort
un choix qui paradoxalement ne fera que
confirmer l'évolution du personnage vers
la bonté
d'abord parce que ce choix montre bien
que végéta a besoin d'être sous
l'emprise d'un être maléfique pour
devenir cruelle et aussi parce que même
sous cette emprise
il conservera son amour pour son fils et
sa bienveillance à l'égard des terriens
pour lesquels est sacrifié à sa vie
[Musique]
le parcours de végéta l'a conduit à
évoluer mais plus encore à être
conscient de son évolution
en cela il est l'incarnation du concept
développé par le philosophe allemand
hegel la dialectique la dialectique est
une notion qui a pour but de décrire la
manière dont la conscience évolue hors
eagle théorise le principe selon lequel
l'évolution de la conscience passe
nécessairement par trois stades
l'affirmation l'opposition et la
réconciliation
végéta s'est opposé aux terriens avant
de rejoindre leur camp il s'est
confronté à leur système de valeurs
un système de valeurs qu'ils rejettent
mais auquel il doit d'être encore en vie
de cette confrontation avec l'autre de
cette lutte contre cet adversaire qu'il
méprise pour sa bonté mais qu'il
respecte pour sa puissance va naître la
dialectique personnel de végéta son
accès à une étape supérieure de la
conscience dans laquelle le bien et le
mal sont réconciliés végéta ne devient
jamais le contraire de végéta il porte
en lui la dualité qui le constituent
jusqu'au jour où arrivant au terme de
son évolution
végéta ont gravi la dernière marche
lorsqu'il reconnaît en son for intérieur
la supériorité de sangoku sur lui
végéta devient alors un personnage
accompli un personnage qui a parcouru
toutes les étapes de son chemin évolutif
avant de devenir qui il est et de
l'accepter
[Musique]
puissance de voir évolution tels sont
les maîtres mots de la philosophie de
végéta un personnage que rien ne
prédestinait à devenir le préféré des
fans de la série mais dont la part
sombre et l'évolution ne peuvent que
faire écho à ce que nous sommes
au fond c'est peut-être ça qui fait de
végéta le personnage le plus humain de
l'univers dragon ball celui qui en
partagent des défauts les qualités et le
pouvoir de s'améliorer
[Musique]